[موسيقى]
حسابات ترامب المعلقه على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي تعود اليه واحده تلو الاخرى قبل
ايام من انطلاق اول فاعليه انتخابيه له من
مدينه كولومبيا في ولايه ساسكارولاين
[موسيقى]
عوده الحسابات ستمكن ترامب من استخدامها
لتمويل حملته الانتخابيه والتواصل مع
قاعده مخلصه التي بقيت معه واعلنت ولا
اهتم لهم
كويس
ان الرئيس السابق ترامب يريد اعاده تنشيط
حسابات على فيسبوك او انستغرام او تويتر
لانه يمتلك شركه تواصل اجتماعي خاصه بها
وهي تروس سولشله لذلك فهو لا يريد
بالضروره ان يقود المتابعين الى النايل
سات اخرى وبالتالي مساعده الاخرين على كسب
المال متابعوام على الفيسبوك ووصلوا الى
34 مليون متابع اما انستغرام فالرقم وتعدى
23 مليون
صادر عن شركه متى الملكه لفيسبوك
وانستجرام تحدثت عن الحاجه الى ضمان حريه
التعبير وتبادل الافكار وان قرار التعليق
جاء في ظروف اضطراريه والظرف الاضطراري
واحداث السادس من يناير حيث اتهم الرئيس
ترامب بتحريضه مؤيديه على مهاجمه مبنى
الكابيتل امر شكل صدمه للام ومنذ ذلك
الوقت وحسابات الرئيس ترامب معلقه ولم
يكتب اي شيء حتى الان منذ السادس من يناير
اما ترامب فقال لا ينبغي منع اي رئيس
مجددا من استخدام وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وعبر حسابه في تونس سوشيال قال ان فيسبوك
الذي خسر مليارات الدولارات من قيمته منذ
حظر رئيسكم المفضل الذي هو انا والكلام
لترامب اعلن للتو انه سيعيد تفعيله حسابي
ناديا باللبس العربيه وعشان